okay so we were behind the scenes here
at the Game Awards 2016 I'm super
excited you guys have seen past couple
years the show has been so much fun so
here I feel like everybody out really
quiet really quickly so I'm about to
present an award with Matt no pressure
no pressure there's a teleprompter we
find kind of nervous
are you really a little please stop it
now I'm gonna get nervous are you
nervous yet no you should be do you know
how many people are watching right now
stop it they're streaming in China - I
know they're China in China in China
they're everywhere this is literally
being streamed every I know it's pretty
it's a big deal stop it okay the one and
only Michael Phelps from the world's
best Jean cruise
We Need to Talk what people are very
very very very upset why don't you write
like that all about the GoPro yes I've
been talking about in the past like
seven vlogs well I've got a surprise my
car could be a GoPro could be your
PlayStation Pro four back or it could be
your $400 for the PlayStation 4 Pro it's
not fun if it's not a surprise
I do like surprise it's in the car and
I'm very excited I am here the game
award out of Justine how are you doing
I'm doing absolutely wonderful were you
at the game Awards I presented an award
where I did all my a my makeup done my
teeth always a guy yeah no it looks
great thank you very much yes we're done
Game Awards 2016 I like I like I like
the uh it looks like Maddie yeah I've
done like a like a shame to the body and
I put it on my body
yep guys hate it I'm really tired
I could be tired from drinking too much
wine then you know now of course that's
not the reason
Jenna help how do you drink wine and
then not feel awful why don't you have
one glass and I feel fine so that's the
secret but but the guy kept coming by
and putting more wine into my glass the
guy wasn't coming to my table so finding
my glass and pouring it and I would turn
and I'll be like ah it's full again
we're off to Disney today I'm so excited
I've wanted to go to Disney for quite a
while and it's Christmas times I love
going to Disney during the Christmas
holiday season because there's lights
and there's fun and it's festive and it
should be super cool it where's Matt I
don't know Edd's joining us we're also
meeting boogie there and his wife so I'm
so so pumped up to get our Disney on
let's see if I have my
we'll pass out my bag is heavy oh I have
it I have it I have it locks into the
hallway did you see my hat that I put on
guys look at me I've got a cake a slider
hat on and what its gonna look like
Maddie you guys are not gonna believe
what Matt got me is at you know all the
mean things that I've said about you and
breaking my GoPro I take it all back
because this is something that I've
wanted really really bad the blog
snapchat spikes I'm glad that there was
a surprise though you should see my
reaction when he showed it to me like I
was flailing I was punching the sky the
air the couch I can send you the footage
if you'd like yeah maybe I'll put a
little clip in right here oh my god yeah
I was excited let's open these up
god I'm so pumped about this this is
unbelievable oh look at them yeah these
are so much tighter cuz these have had
so many people spaces on them because
they kept putting them on and now
they're all stretched out I do all that
bring his oh this is so exciting what
does that mean
does that mean I'm here look at these
specs Matt
oh no go get them now so Sami we're
going so we're going so slow so we're on
our way to Disney um we picked up a tad
what later what this hey hey
what Matt over there look at this you
got along with all our specs now this is
like the best thing this was a biggest
surprise in my life oh yeah we can't go
to the drive-through
oops surprised because I forgot that
you're supposed to be going no we're
here and we're going and I was like I
just landed off on the plane he hopped
up the plane at LAX with us Karthik
jittery yet again in the car oh the
dream and the car did you download Mario
maker yet no okay
yeah oh but I got a charged up charge a
charge up I drop ideas just Justine's
phone it looks like Jason Derulo just
keeps staring at her staring really but
how am I supposed to go was a liar one
two lane you gotta go so I'm running
solo you drive this awesome idea we do
the all the single riders Oh the single
riders what what um - Brock - fries
we're at Portillo's matt is inside
getting the shots for his vlog I just I
love making fun of him like I do
appreciate that he is stepping up his
vlog game but he hopped out of the car
so he could go outside and film we made
it to Disney many hours later I mean we
had made a quick we made a lot of stops
where the Patil's I had to go to
bathroom there were some emergencies but
we're here it is so cold Jen coke
in the side of the track away from the
Sun sitting with me too close to me we
will be coming here to the Disneyland
Resort main hundred of our friends thank
you look how many friends we have he's
getting the shot
so my Disney tradition is every time I
underestimate how cold it's going to be
so I end up buying a hat
every time here it's not a hat a
sweatshirt or something hey what's
happening
Jeff is here celebrating successful
postgame Awards I'm just hanging out
down Anaheim you might for PlayStation
experience are actually the game Awards
is before this vlog it's all in one oh
it's all one was all one vlog I didn't
blow it up yesterday so okay well so
yeah any time to game work I had
excellent time yes you were great on
stage presenting thank you you are
joining us you were great on stage the
whole time that was a lot a lot number
how you do it that's pretty crazy
that's insane we wrapped it up and now
now we rest what's out really I did this
there we are I need about a hat so I'm
gonna find a hair join for the very
special guest buggy yeah so
congratulations trending game of the
year how do you feel
frankly I feel like me I guess which is
how am I supposed to feel that's what
nobody will tell me I just feel like me
yeah it's great though I feel like I
have one more statue then I had
yesterday actually feels really good I'm
not gonna lie yeah my Twitter was on
fire all day everybody super happy
that's what makes me happy made other
people happy
yeah that makes me super happy I was so
excited I didn't even know because I was
backstage and then I was like man I did
you trying to game her yet and then I
went and checked on like yes I was like
freaking out of my seat oh yeah
they had Peter Moore give me that fries
we Peter me and Peter Moore go way back
like mmm you know what I'm saying yeah
and I love that man honestly he's these
things a good guy Peter if you're
watching this I'm sorry for calling you
a Bond villain we're gonna go have some
more fun at dizzy so let's go yay it's
like so no this is really cool like
actual cold
you
Disney is so awesome with my freaking
loved is here I'm so happy right now man
I'm eating a chair oh yeah you look
really cool
pre sweet yeah please feet off ya like
my hat my post game Morris has the only
how we can find what's it magic it just
is always you fine I think that doesn't
for Disney it's just so cold
I think I'm not I'm not having a good
time anymore
like I'm trying but like I feel like I'm
gonna cry yeah I was crying when they
played that snow and I realized I was
cold no brother to be real snow upset
but it wasn't real if we get a Starbucks
we're walking we made it back from
Disney so late last night and I was so
tired that I say - Jenna's health so
we're here getting some breakfast and
then we're going to pick Maddie get from
this trainer he's had a really fun time
he's been going on hikes and he's been
just having basically the time of his
life without us and we're gonna go get
him and we're gonna play with him and
save mommies our home just picked up the
baby boy from the groomers he looks so
handsome and I'm gonna head home because
I'm playing Super Mario maker I think
until my eyes fall out I played it a
bunch on Wii U but now if I can take
this game with me basically anywhere
you better believe that's what I'm doing
this weekend so let's go home and play
video games Maddie Randy off to third
Streets it's been a wild couple of days
we did Game Awards who would Disney and
now we're gonna go eat dinner
I guess Street passes yes did you get um
uh Super Mario maker yet did you get
super mario maker yet mhm yes like
downloaded it already
I'm download it now okay good let's go
I look silly get this one doesn't go
with anything that I am but it can be
your my style
Oh Santa ours Santa's closed I'm so
salad it's a Saturday
I'm gonna ticket love running into
people on 3rd Street they like no but
we're always here I know
right now
we just had a really great meal and now
it's time to go home and finish this
vlog it's pretty much the past couple of
days hope you guys have enjoyed the
wonderful couple days of vlogs even
though you've probably seen everything
that I have posted in this video in
everyone else's videos so that's it
okay bye bye just hey dusty now they're
stuck together Oh shoo shoo am i me oh
oh my god I am so sorry I'm so sorry
I thought I had a handle on that and I
cannot I did not have a handle on that
oh my god